c'est pour ça que j'ai rédigé ce livre
sous la forme d'une chronique parce que
je me suis dit on a vécu quelque chose
de tellement sidérant
au sens propre du terme que dès que la
vie va reprendre on va l'oublier
1 donc j'ai tenu à raconter au jour le
jour ce qui s'est passé et je me suis
rendu compte que au tout début il y
avait un vague texte du code de la santé
publique qui disait que le ministre de
la santé peut prendre toutes les mesures
utiles si un problème de d'épidémie
ouais un peu court donc très rapidement
le gouvernement a fait voter par le
parlement une loi un peu plus détaillée
mais à chaque fois on a vu que à une
mesure dans la pratique elle était
comment dire exercé enfin appliquer de
manière extrêmement abusive je prendre
un exemple je regarde beaucoup la presse
évidemment c'est mon métier d'avocat de
revient la presse pour analyser les
choses et je suis tombé sur nice matin
sur une vidéo qui m'a mais effrayé nous
étions la première période de
confinement ces interdictions de sortie
est chez soi sauf alors y'a pas de
masque à l'époque parce que vous
souvenez madame ndiaye il disait je sais
même pas comment le mettre ça sert à
rien très bien et donc c'est l'heure de
sortie d'un père de famille place
masséna à nice il avec ses deux bambins
de 6 et 4 ans et tout d'un coup un drone
arrive qu'il eut braille dessus arrêtez
vous immédiatement jusqu'à ce que les
policiers municipaux viennent vous
contrôlez lesquels arrivent le monsieur
avait soit son auto attestation en bonne
et due forme
un truc déjà y verront de toute façon le
côté comme la ville de nice étaient
ravis de cette innovation moderne
tellement france 3 régions étaient là
pour filmer demande au monsieur alors
qu'est ce qu'on avait pensé et il dit
deux choses très intéressantes il dit
j'ai été extrêmement choqué mais bon je
comprends c'est la servitude volontaire
si vous voulez et moi je me dis mais ses
deux enfants là mais quelques l impact
sur le psychisme que ce robot mécanisée
alors ça c'est extrêmement important
parce que c'est pour répondre à votre
question oui à une pandémie c'est un
problème qui est majeure oui le
gouvernement prend des mesures qui sont
des mesures de sécurité de lutte contre
la pandémie
mais on a tout de suite des mesures qui
sont totalement délirante et cette
histoire de drones en est la meilleure
démonstration
[Musique]